the storyteller folds her slender hands
both pairs and speaks
it happened an age ago
but when i recall i see it true
so begins the tale of the shattering a
devastating war between the children of
america
demigods of the lands between
one grim night in the depths of winter a
flock of unknown assassins stole across
the lands between
in a coetaneous attack this foul
covenant snuffed out the lives of many
of the god queen's kin throughout the
empire too numerous and too scattered
for her godly protection to save the
assassins targets were multifold but
none were as devastating a loss to the
eternal queen as that of godwin the
golden
after his death the elden ring was
somehow shattered and the order of the
world broke with it
out of this chaos came war
open bitter war
pitting blood against blood and kin
against kin
the conflict broke a vast and prosperous
empire into brittle fragments
no single side could find enough
purchase to maintain a decisive victory
even when fueled by the power of a great
rune
the battle of general radon against
millennia the severed illustrated that
neither strength nor skill alone would
be enough to take control of the
entirety of the lands murica had united
and so the lands between are no longer
gripped by open war but caught in an
uneasy stalemate that seems impossible
to resolve
unless of course the storyteller says a
koi smile on both her lips
thou should take the crown